oh yes arm so trustworthy been a while
since I've done a nitpick grant and I'm
gonna have a little a little venting
about the Dark Knight Rises now that
might seem like an odd thing it's not a
new movie at this point it's a movie
that's been pretty picked over as well
as far as you know it's issues go and
there's plenty of stuff to pick on all
over the place with this thing there's a
you know everything from how did Bruce
Wayne get from that hole back to Gotham
why did the entire GCPD go into the
sewers but like those are things that
have been picked over by so many people
like that's cliche to bring that stuff
up no I want to talk about the thing
that bugs me about this film that has
bugged me from the very first time that
I saw it and this is not the only film
I've seen at him but it is the one of
the more prominent examples why does
anyone believe Bane so the scene I'm
talking about specifically this is after
Bane has you know revealed that he has a
bomb he's holding the city hostage he's
isolated it and he rolls up with tanks
and he takes out this speech written by
Commissioner Gordon about how Harvey
Dent
wasn't the Paragon and martyr that he
has been remembered as and the and he
puts to shame this whole notion of the
dent act that the city has been using to
help clean up the streets because Harvey
Dent tried to kill Jim Gordon's son and
he was a monster Jim Gordon has been
perpetuating a lie that's what this
statement says
and Bane reads it to the masses yes Jim
Gordon reveals that this man he was no
hero and the results of that is the city
basically falls apart
and I went back and re-watch this I
checked this now to be fair part of this
as Bane's own doing like he does like
basically blow a hole in the prison and
a bunch of person just come out but like
right after that ordinary people are
storming the street and smashing up
penthouses and they appear to be going
after the wealthy and the rich the film
seems to be trying to say that revealing
the lie that Gotham has been subsisting
on for the past however long the gap is
between the movies I'll forget that
makes everything crumble except why
would anyone believe Bane now we as the
audience have a reason to believe him
because we know that that speech is
authentic we've seen it and we get to
see Gordon's reaction when he realizes
Bane's have it so we know it's
legitimate but the film uses that as an
excuse to get away with explaining oh so
the people know too why why would the
people believe him this is a guy who
showed up out of nowhere hasn't asked
and talks workers and he he's using a
bomb to threaten the city
he's rolling tanks through he's blowing
up the prison and releasing everybody
and he holds up a piece of paper and he
says this piece of paper proves this
city is a lie and everyone
goes oh I'm sorry what the only way that
works is a if it is verifiably authentic
which it's not as presented it would
have been one thing like if I don't know
if Jim Gordon had like practiced the
speech on his own and Bane had gotten
someone to to take video of him doing
that so they knew it was Gordon that
would be evidence that it was Gordon's
own words because otherwise it's just a
piece of paper so that doesn't work so
the only other way this works is if
Gotham is in such a state everything is
so screwed up that basically people are
just waiting for the excuse all the fuel
is there somebody just needed to light
the match but that doesn't work here not
in this Gotham not in a Gotham that has
been so quiet that Batman has been
retired retired Batman the walking
embodiment of obsession has not felt the
need to come back
that's how stable it is no no even if
you're gonna say it the only way it got
this way was the dent Act and it's in
Harvey Dent's memory so if we take that
it goes away okay but who's gonna
believe a crazy person with a piece of
paper why would this one nutjob speaking
caused the common people to lose their
minds like this now this if you saw my
review of Joker I had a lot of mixed
feelings about that movie but this is an
area where that movie managed to pull
off what Dark Knight Rises tries and
fails to do because Gotham City as
presented in Joker absolutely is such a
mess of a city that it just takes
somebody to light the match and throw it
on the mess that's already there the
whole thing goes up in flames
Joker cell
Gotham is being that kind of city Dark
Knight Rises fails maybe Gotham was that
back in Batman Begins but even at the
time of the Dark Knight like the entire
point of the Dark Knight was even when
put in a situation where it where they
have every encouragement to give up
their morals the people still don't do
it if the Joker couldn't pull it off
Bane reader that commercial traitor gets
the people to rise up and start to eat
each other in a way that the Joker only
dreamed of no no there is no freaking
way that anybody would ever believe this
guy oh and of course everyone just
happened to find out because look he's
just standing on a freaking street
corner with a megaphone yes he's being
recorded on TV but he's literally
everybody in the city watching TV at
that exact time well I know it's a
standard trope in TV and movies that
it's like the the expositional news
network the news exactly what you need
exactly when you need it and that's how
news works in movies but like come
freakin on it's one thing to make that
leap for one character who needs a
specific piece of information from the
news you're basically saying that
literally the entire city is watching
nothing but the news and yes I know the
situation that they're in but I'm sorry
if I'm stuck in that situation I'm
hunkering down and I'm watching comfort
food maybe it's just me maybe I'm nuts
but they do not sell Gotham as being
crazy enough on the brink enough for
this to work and I hate this as a thing
I hate when a character says something
and then all the other characters
involved just believe them when they
have no reason to one of the first
videos I ever did on this channel that
wasn't one of the scripted shorts you go
way back it was a video talking about
why do we as an audience believe Darth
Vader when he says I am your father
to Luke Skywalker because we shouldn't
there is no way we should believe him he
is the bad guy he is every reason to
live we have every reason to doubt him
he has no credibility but that moment
works
I even talked about specifically why cuz
that has things that play multiple
layers between Luke's reaction and the
music that is brought in and the weight
of it that it is given it sells that
more to the point it sells it to this
one character who has to buy it as
opposed to an entire freaking city who
not only has to believe this guy but
they also have to all come to the
conclusion well grab your truncheon and
go after the one percent I'm sorry no
that's stupid and that is the element
and aspect of the Dark Knight Rises that
drives me crazy but is one that I feel
like nobody ever talks about so there
you go this is my my nitpick rant on
that one I've had that on the list to do
for a long time it is not topical or
relevant anymore if it ever was from
what I was planning to talk about it but
man feels good to get that off my chest
quick word about this video sponsor my
patreon because if you disagree with
YouTube but believe that I should earn
money off of what I put up here and you
don't think copyright holders with no
understanding affair you should be able
to take the revenue from me
well patreon is a great way to show me
that you care about what I do because
you do then give a crap so with that
little bit out of the way yes there is a
patreon link down below you can help me
out with that but you know what also
helps hitting like hitting subscribe
sharing the video and if whatever
thoughts you have about this drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it other stuff down there as well
link to my other social media stuff and
other things besides like the book I
wrote and things of that nature so click
on stuff the buttons the links they take
your places they do things or don't you
don't have to because at the end of the
day you're the council I'm just running
the meanings and until next time this
council is wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]